comme il est de tradition
les
comptes rendus et les éléments de la
récente réunion du Conseil européen des
29 et 30 juin dernier réunion que le
chef d'État priorent après maturément
quitté en raison des des violences
urbaines qui secouaient notre pays je ne
m'étendrai pas sur ces questions de
politique intérieure sinon pour
regretter que l'image de la France en
Europe a été encore une fois un peu
écornée un peu beaucoup même d'autant
que la visite d'État du président Macron
en Allemagne a aussi été reporté
quelques semaines après l'annulation de
la visite du roi Charles en France j'en
reviens à la réunion du Conseil européen
qui s'est tenu en présence du secrétaire
général de l'OTAN et du président
zellinski dans le contexte nouveau
résultant de la rébellion du patron du
groupe Wagner rigogym qui a fait
vaciller le Kremlin pendant presque 24
heures
nous nous félicitons du contraste que
cet épisode a donné à voir entre la
fragilisation du pouvoir russe et
l'unité constante du côté européen en
soutien à l'Ukraine mais au-delà nous
serions intéressés de savoir quelle
analyse faire de se repli finalement
effectué par Prigogine un moment je me
suis demandé s'il y avait pas là une
grande opération cinématographique
concernant l'Ukraine toujours je vous
avais fait part lors du débat préalable
au Conseil européen dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat qui se tenait la veille d'un
corépère décisif de notre inquiétude au
sujet de la proposition législative
européenne ASAP destinée à accélérer la
production de munitions au vu du
caractère très intrusif des pouvoirs que
la Commission réclamée à cet effet dans
un domaine qui est évidemment régalien
pourriez-vous nous rassurer sur ce point
au-delà de la simple mention que nous
avons relevé dans les conclusions du
Conseil européen qui précisait que la
réponse aux besoins urgent de l'Ukraine
en matière militaire doit être apportée
sans préjudice du caractère spécifique
de la politique de sécurité et de
défense de certains États membres et
contenu des intérêts de tous les États
membres en matière de sécurité et de
défense
c'est quand même à décrypter par
ailleurs le Conseil européen confirmait
la perspective de l'élargissement de
l'Union européenne à l'Ukraine et à la
Moldavie mais aussi au balcon
occidentaux qui attendaient sans doute
un tel signal entre-temps le Kosovo a
été sanctionné et privé de subventions
de l'Union européenne pour des projets
relevants du cadre d'investissement en
faveur des Balkans occidentaux
pouvez-vous nous préciser sur quel
fondement ont été pris ces sanctions
dont les conclusions du Conseil européen
ne présageait pas puisqu'elle se limite
à appeler à la désescalade entre le
Kosovo et la Serbie dans quelle mesure
ces sanctions risquent elles de mettre
en péril la trajectoire européenne du
Kosovo à moyen terme dans le but d'y
ramener le calme à court terme
comme attendu concernant l'élargissement
le Conseil européen n'a malheureusement
pas initié de débats à ce stade sur la
capacité d'absorption de l'Union
capacité que j'avais interrogé lors de
notre débat du 20 juin dans l'hémicycle
mais il semble que ce débat s'amorce
enfin à l'ouverture du sommet des 27 à
Bruxelles le président du Conseil
européen Charles Michel avait déclaré
que le débat sur les réformes à mener
pour l'intégrer l'Ukraine était
désormais indispensable tout en
reconnaissant qu'il serait difficile et
en marge du Conseil européen le
président de la République est le
premier ministre néerlandais marquer
route ont partagé un petit déjeuner avec
8 autres chefs d'État ou de gouvernement
pour entamer une réflexion sur ces
réformes préalables à l'élargissement
tant en manière en matière
institutionnelle que sur le fond des
politiques européennes pourriez-vous
nous dire nous en dire plus madame la
ministre sur le contenu de ces échanges
tout qui ont été tenus en marge du
conseil
concernant la relation entre l'Union
européenne et la Chine les conclusions
du Conseil européen plaident pour des
conditions de concurrence équitables
afin que la relation commerciale a
économique soit équilibrée réciproque et
mutuellement bénéfiques et appel à
réduire les dépendances et les
vulnérabilités critiques de l'Union
envers la Chine y compris dans ces
chaînes d'approvisionnement Conseil
européen en perd toutefois en précisant
que l'Union européenne n'a pas
d'intention de découplage ou de repli
sur elle-même ce qui sonne comme une
concession faite à l'Allemagne dans le
chancelier a récemment déclaré que ce
découplage d’avec la Chine devait pas
être organisée par les autorités
publiques mais relever des seules
entreprises n'y a-t-il pas là une forme
d'angélisme alors que depuis la Chine a
demandé aux représentants avec une
semaine de préavis seulement d'annuler
sa visite et qu'à la répliqué aux
nouvelles restrictions néerlandaise sur
l'export vers la Chine de puces avancée
en restreignant à son tour l'export vers
l'Union européenne de la matière
première indispensable aux transition
verte et numérique et même à notre
industrie de défense la divergence entre
nos pays et l'Allemagne entre notre pays
et l'Allemagne pardon sur la relation
avec la Chine est-elle selon vous
irrémédiable enfin sur le sujet
migratoire et pas des moindres nous
notons qu'il n'a pas été possible au
Conseil européen de parvenir à des
conclusions partagées 25 pays ont
soutenu les conclusions prévues
encourageant l'action extérieure de
l'Union pour juguler les flux
migratoires mais malgré l'ajout d'un
alinéa annonçant le renforcement du
soutien au pays qui accueille des
réfugiés Ukrainiens la Pologne et la
Hongrie ne se sont pas ralliés au
consensus cela signifie-t-il que la
perspective de conclure le nouveau pacte
Asie l'immigration de la présidente
espagnole affiche comme une priorité
j'allais dire elle n'a pas été la seule
depuis plusieurs présidents et hors
d'atteinte madame la mini je vous cède
la parole en espérant obtenir les
réponses plus précises que celles que
l'on a vu dans les conclusions
et je donnerai ensuite la parole à mes
collègues à commencer par Monsieur Kern
qui a demandé assez rapidement la parole
puisqu'il doit nous quitter allez
monsieur le Président je vous remercie
mesdames c'est Netflix et messieurs les
sénateurs je suis ravie de vous
retrouver
assez rapidement après le 20 juin quand
je vous avais présenté les enjeux du
conseil pour venir vous rendre compte à
des résultats principaux résultats
obtenus et des discussions comme vous
l'avez mentionné la première partie du
Conseil européen évidemment été sur la
situation en Ukraine et notamment sur
les questions de défense et sécurité
la première chose était de discuter avec
le secrétaire général de l'OTAN en
préparation des sommets des 11 et 12
juillet à Vilnius
là lors de ces discussions les États
membres se sont engagés collectivement à
ce que à la fois l'Union européenne et
ses États membres puissent contribuer au
futur garanties de sécurité qui aideront
l'Ukraine à se défendre dans la durée
l'idée était évidemment fournir un
soutien et des garanties suffisamment
forts pour dissuader toute agression ou
toute tentative de déstabilisation de
façon pérenne
et c'est un point que le président avait
évoqué dans ces dans son discours à
Bratislava le 31 mai dernier
voilà donc c'était important d'avoir
cette première discussion ensuite
toujours sur l'Ukraine il y a une
discussion sur la livraison de matériel
militaire ou comme vous le savez
l'idée est à nouveau de répondre aux
besoins criniens dans la durée mais ils
sont bien évidemment pénalisés les
nôtres c'est pour cela que le président
a exprime le fait qu'il fallait passer à
une économie de guerre
et par là ce qui est ce que les chefs
d'État est gouvernement veulent dire
c'est renforcer les capacités de
production de l'industrie de défense
européenne notamment les propositions à
travers les achats conjoints et c'est le
projet et dire pas que vous connaissez
bien et également le soutien à la
production de munitions et de missiles
ASAP que vous avez mentionné monsieur le
Président ou l'idée est vraiment de
préserver également les compétences
nationales et les bien sûr les intérêts
de nos industries
voilà en outre les chefs d'État est
gouvernement ont demandé à la Commission
de présenter d'ici à la fin de l'année
des propositions qui soient concrètes
dans le cadre du programme européen
d'investissement dans la défense et deep
ensuite
après le côté militaire je crois qu'on
peut tous être d'accord que la stabilité
du continent ne sera assurée durablement
que lorsque nous aurons une famille
européenne unie et comme vous l'avez
émotionné il y a eu à la fois la
discussion conseiller européen sur les
progrès de l'Ukraine et de la Moldavie
sur leur chemin de l'adhésion à l'Union
européenne et également sur la nécessité
de transformer l'Union européenne pour
l'arrivée des nouveaux États membres
vous avez mentionné le petit déjeuner en
marge du Conseil j'étais effectivement
un tour de table informel qui était là
pour traiter à la fois de comment est-ce
qu'on pouvait mieux réussir la vision
des pays candidats donc quel type de
soutien de quel type de soutien il peut
avoir besoin
notamment pour être assuré des
institutions du respect de l'État de
droit dans la durée et puis les
transformations qui seront nécessaires
au sein de l'Union européenne en matière
de politique en matière de budget en
matière de gouvernance
et bien sûr ce sera suivi
d'autres d'autres réunions il y a d'une
part le groupe de travail
franco-allemand que nous avons mis en
place avec mon homologue allemand qui
devrait rendre des
conclusions des options en espérant au
mois de septembre et puis de façon plus
formelle il y aura le discours sur
l'état de l'Union bien sûr mais le
Conseil européen informel de Grenade où
il y aura le rapport cette fois formel
sur l'élargissement et la date de
décembre à être prise la décision
d'ouvrir les négociations à l'adhésion
ou non
donc voilà où on en est sur
l'élargissement il y avait un énorme
pardon un très grand bloc économie lors
de ce Conseil européen avec les enjeux
de compétitivité et de sécurité
économique comme vous savez il y avait
déjà été l'objet de décision en février
et en mars et donc je vais vous
rendre compte sur les principaux piliers
d'abord la réforme du marché de
l'électricité évidemment elle est
essentielle pour que nous ayons des prix
à la fois qui soient plus bas et plus
stable tout en fin continuant de
favoriser l'investissement dans les
sources des carbonées et là le Conseil a
décidé d'un calendrier ambitieux pour
achever les négociations évidemment
l'idée c'est d'arriver à fond la fin de
l'année mais surtout le plus vite
possible de façon à donner des
perspectives et de la visibilité au
ménage comme aux entreprises
et quant à nous nous avons refait le
point et nous continuerons de le faire
de la neutralité technologique entre les
différentes sources d'énergie
décarbonées vous y avez d'ailleurs
invité dans votre résolution du 19 juin
ça c'est le premier bloc économique ça a
été suivi de la réforme des règles
budgétaires qui sera évidemment
importante pour encourager les
investissements qui vont être
nécessaires à la transition écologique à
la transition numérique et pour soutenir
une croissance durable mais aussi pour
s'assurer que nos finances publiques
soient soutenables et là aussi les
discussions sont encore en cours et
enfin le troisième point c'est
l'accélération de la réindustrialisation
du continent et l'idée est vraiment de
préserver notre leadership dans
l'innovation et de rester à la pointe de
l'innovation technologique et donc là on
a pu passer en revue et insister sur
certains points en ce qui concerne le
cadre temporaire pour les règles pour
les êtres d'État le règlement européen
sur les semi-conducteurs le règlement
européen sur les matières premières
critiques et la législation sur
l'industrie net 0
qui bien sûr est en ligne avec celle qui
est actuellement discutée au Parlement
ce que nous voulions vraiment aussi à la
fois un choc de simplification réduire
la biocratie européenne avoir une
politique industrielle moderne donc qui
vise les secteurs stratégiques qui
permettent la croissance de l'emploi et
puis s'assurer que nous renforçons notre
souveraineté technologique dans la
décarbonation
enfin puisque comme vous saviez nous
avons demandé à ce que avec
l'assouplissement des aides d'État on
puisse avoir plus de flexibilité et un
fond de souveraineté pour les pays qui
n'ont pas le même espace budgétaire que
les autres et pour éviter une
fragmentation de l'Union européenne nous
avons dû insister beaucoup mais la
Commission a enfin présenté une
proposition pour créer un fond de
souveraineté qui lui visera
effectivement des investissements
stratégiques dans toute l'Union
européenne
alors sur la souveraineté l'économie
toujours je crois qu'il y avait un pan
de la souveraineté dont nous avons
beaucoup discuté avec vous et qui est
important pour les Français qui est la
santé et évidemment il s'agit là aussi
d'assurer sur le sol européen la
production de médicaments essentiels
d'arrêter de voir des personnes de voir
chercher de pharmacie en pharmacie ce
dont elles ont besoin donc pour cela
l'Union européenne se fixera des
objectifs de production sur le sol
européen un peu comme nous avons fait
avec les puces électroniques et va se
doter des instruments nécessaires pour
atteindre ses objectifs je crois que
c'est important pour montrer comme
l'Union européenne et au service des
personnes et de leur vie quotidienne et
puis le dernier volant c'est la sécurité
économique européenne qui était en lien
avec mais pas que la Chine donc là pour
être précise il s'agit d'abord de
protéger le marché intérieur contre la
concurrence déloyale d'exiger la
réciprocité en matière d'ouverture de
marché public de nous prémunir contre
des achats d'entreprises stratégiques
sur notre sol ou des investissements qui
nuraient à notre souveraineté évidemment
je pense par exemple à la protection des
données que nous produisons et de se
fixer des règles sur les transferts
technologiques et un mode opératoire et
là encore il s'agit de consolider la
souveraineté de l'Union européenne voilà
pour ce large volant économique et comme
vous l'avez relevé à monsieur le
Président les chefs d'états ont consacré
assez longue partie de leurs échanges
aux migrations
alors je crois pour être équilibré je
crois qu'il faut il faut reconnaître que
nous avons fait beaucoup de progrès sur
ce qui concerne la dimension
interne avec l'accord qui avait été
trouvé sur les deux textes majeurs du
pacte asile et migrations et que sous la
qui avait été débloqué sous la
présidence française de l'Union
européenne un accord qui était bloqué
depuis 10 ans donc on voit bien que
c'est un sujet difficile
ces deux textes sont importants parce
qu'ils permettent de renforcer les
frontières extérieures tout en traitant
plus rapidement les demandes d'asile et
en assurant notre sécurité
donc voilà si comme vous le disiez ce
travail accompli sous les présidents
françaises puis c'est de ta saluer
effectivement les discussions entre chef
d'État n'ont pas permis d'adopter des
conclusions consensuelles sur le sujet
migratoire c'est regrettable parce que
ce sujet doit évidemment être traité à
27 aucun État membre ne peut faire face
seul
assez enjeux nous restons toujours
confiant dans le fait qu'il faut en tous
les cadrer résolument volontariste pour
arriver à
clore le pactasie immigration sous la
présidence espagnole et je rappelle que
les discussions ont finalement concerné
un tout petit nombre de pays
qui est tout petit nombre de pays de
parties OCR qui ont fait beaucoup de
discussions alors qu'il y avait un
accord qui avait été trouvé encore
sur
les en tous les cas réglait le point de
première entrée et puis comme vous le
dites la réolocalisation n'était pas
obligatoire puisque c'est soit on prend
des personnes soit en contribue
financièrement donc c'était
de textes qui sont équilibrés entre
effectivement gérer les frontières
extérieures prendre en compte le cas des
pays de première entrée de ceux qui vous
fait des efforts dessus dans la
situation fait qu'il préfère contribuer
financièrement ici franchement un bon
texte
sur la dimension externe d'immigration
les chefs gouvernement sont engagés à
poursuivre les travaux dans la ligne des
progrès qui ont été effectués avec la
Tunisie et dans l'espoir de dans le dans
l'idée de reproduire ces avancées avec
d'autres pays de la région voilà j'ai
bientôt fini le dernier volant c'était
les relations extérieures comme vous le
savez il y a eu beaucoup de discussions
sur notre relation à la Chine
à la fois pour qu'elle joue un rôle plus
constructif quand s'agissant de la
guerre d'agression que la rue Chimène
contre l'Ukraine à la fois sur les
échanges économiques qui doivent être
équilibrés mais ils doivent pas nuire à
nos intérêts stratégiques comme je le
disais sur la partie sécurité économique
et puis en s'assurant que la Chine
continue de jouer son rôle dans les
grands enjeux globaux comme le climat la
protection des pandémies etc
il y a également une discussion sur le
règlement de la question chypriote les
tensions entre le Kosovo et la Serbie
comme vous le mentionnez essentiellement
pour rappeler à chacune des parties à
respecter les accords sur lesquels elles
se sont engagées et surtout à les mettre
en oeuvre puisque c'est là que se trouve
le blocage et des escaladé dans la
tension qui est en train qui menace de
s'installer et puis enfin il y a eu un
mot mais vous avez dû en parler avec
l'ambassadeur espagnol sur la
préparation du sommet qui va se tenir en
juillet entre les pays
latino-américains et l'Union européenne
et enfin sur les événements puisque vous
les avez mentionnés monsieur le
Président je peux vous assurer puisque
j'étais en Allemagne et j'ai vu le
président Steinmeyer qui est absolument
compris pourquoi la visite d'État a dû
être reportée et qui se réjouit de la
faire le plus rapidement possible merci
beaucoup
merci
à mes collègues juste un petit point sur
sur la Chine en fait ma question était
tournée sur finalement la relation
franco-allemande par rapport à la Chine
plutôt que la relation directe de la
Chine vis-à-vis de l'Union européenne on
a on a quand même on a compris qu'il y
avait une vision peut-être divergente
sur sur l'approche que l'on avait par
rapport aux chinois mais bon voilà
peut-être qu'elle sera reposée mais elle
était plus plus dans ce sens alors
Claude
merci monsieur le Président pour moi ce
sera très court madame la ministre merci
pour votre exposé parce que vous avez
globalement déjà répondu à mes questions
[Musique]
par rapport aux pays maghrébins je
parlais la Tunisie l'Algérie et le Maroc
qui reste lié quelque part au pacte
ainsi l'immigration puisque c'est une
porte d'entrée
vers l'Union européenne donc je pense
que là aussi l'Union européenne surtout
par rapport au Maroc et la Tunisie ces
derniers temps doit afficher une
position claire
merci Président Madame ministre merci
beaucoup pour vos propos
d'abord je voudrais vous faire part de
quelques inquiétudes
ce qui vient d'être évoqué par mon
collègue sur les capacités de blocage
des pays membres aujourd'hui sur le
pacte d'immigration mais qui pourrait
se produire sur d'autres sujets
notamment sur la révision du cadre
financier pluriannuel dont je vais
parler dans un instant une deuxième
inquiétude sur la déclaration du
Président de la République rejoint
depuis par plusieurs États membres
appelant une pause en matière
environnementale
les transitions à mes yeux
ne sont pas que des contraintes ce sont
aussi des opportunités donc j'aimerais
avoir peut-être des explications sur ce
que souhaite le gouvernement sur le
sujet et puis une troisième inquiétude
sur le Mercosur on en a parlé avec
l'ambassadeur d'Espagne
les négociations qui étaient prévues
entre l'Union européenne et les pays
d'Amérique latine les 29 et 30 juin
dernier ont été annulés par
les pays d'Amérique latine il y a un
sommet qui est prévu sur ce sujet
prochainement avec les Caraïbes aussi
et donc le volet additionnel qui a été
ajouté en matière environnementale et
sociale en matière de respect des droits
humains
n'est qu'optionnel n'a aucune
capacité de contrainte et d'autre part
on a appris que le président brésilien
voulait aussi renégocier
l'ouverture des marchés publics aux
entreprises européennes donc tout ça va
peut-être déboucher sur une remise à
plat de la négociation donc je voudrais
avoir aussi peut-être des informations
là dessus enfin dernier sujet sur le
cadre financier pluriannuel la
Commission a proposé d'injecter 60
milliards d'euros à comparer aux mille
milliards sur la période
consacré à des cibles très précises
l'aide à l'Ukraine les migrations et
puis les salaires des fonctionnaires
européens qui doivent être ajustés au
regard de l'inflation
tout ça ne répond pas aux défis qui sont
devant nous le font de souveraineté fait
des frais de cette forme de d'austérité
et
par rapport
à l'irra la Commission de mec que 10
milliards d'euros sur la table dans le
cadre du dispositif step tout ça tout ça
est est bien faible et donc je voulais
savoir ce qu'il en était du côté des
recettes puisque on nous annonce une
contribution des états équivalentes à
une taxe sur les grandes entreprises à
0,5 points sur les bénéfices donc est-ce
que tout ça a un peu de matière et et
est-ce que ça peut abonder le budget
avec la taxe carbone et les Ets pour
permettre aussi de rembourser la dette
contractée par l'Union européenne dans
le cadre du plan de relance suite à la
covid
si le président madame la ministre dans
son propos liminaire le président
a évoqué la situation de l'Ukraine et
fait référence au la proposition de
règlement en ce qui concerne
les munitions j'ai entendu votre réponse
et permettez-moi de vous dire que je
l'ai trouvé
intéressantes mais comme on dit à la
Cour des comptes pas très documenté je
veux revenir sur deux aspects plus
particulièrement
dans cette affaire il y a une dimension
politique
qui a très au régalien et à la
souveraineté et lorsque je vois qu'à
l'article 13
l'Europe pour obtenir des informations
que l'on nous refuse actuellement dans
le cadre de la LPM concernant les stocks
de munitions je m'interroge sur le point
de savoir qu'est-ce que veut dire
souveraineté nationale si le Parlement
français n'a pas accès au même document
aux mêmes informations que le Parlement
européen et la Commission c'est donc une
question politique et j'aurais souhaité
une réponse plus précise à défaut d'être
plus ferme
le deuxième aspect de cette affaire
il est économique et industriel
on parle d'harmonisation
l'étape d'après l'harmonisation c'est
l'uniformisation
aujourd'hui nous avons une discussion et
elle peine à aboutir elle est longue
elle est compliquée on peut le
comprendre mais nous avons une
discussion notamment avec l'Allemagne
avec l'Espagne aussi sur l'avion du
futur et le char du futur
ne craignez-vous pas que au travers
d'une telle proposition de de règlement
visant à l'harmonisation
on en vienne à pouvoir peut-être
fragiliser l'abbaye d'édité française je
vous remercie
merci merci beaucoup pour ces questions
très intéressantes qui vont permettre à
porter des précisions que vous m'avez
demandé
monsieur et sénateur sur sur les
migrations et la Pologne et la Hongrie
oui comme je vous disais tout à l'heure
si tu as si ironique de voir les trois
pays
ERC ne pas se mettre d'accord alors que
ça devrait être justement alors que
c'est justement de leur fondamentaux de
convergence nous allons continuer les
discussions il y aura les trilogues et
l'intérêt des 27 et vraiment d'arriver à
conclure ce pactasie immigration pour
lequel on avait quand même fait une
annoncée décisive en disant après le
blocage donc les discussions vont
continuer évidemment le Conseil européen
n'est pas le lieu de ces négociations
quand elles sont lisent il faut
reprendre
attache à d'autres niveaux
et bien sûr je suis à votre disposition
pour vous tenir au courant au fur et à
mesure des discussions sur les la
dimension externe
l'idée c'est bien d'arriver à quelque
chose avec la Tunisie maintenant vous
savez qu'il y a des discussions
là-dessus quelque chose d'équilibré ou
effectivement on les aide dans la
gestion de ce qui se passe on est chef
dans leur développement mais évidemment
ce sera conditionnel c'est comme ça elle
est toujours
il y a et ça sera la même chose pour les
autres pays sur lesquels nous sommes
tous en train de travailler je peux vous
assurer qu'il y a une étroite
coopération entre l'Union européenne et
tous les États membres comme vous savez
la présidente de l'Union européenne est
allée avec le Premier ministre
hollandais et avec la présidente du
Conseil italien en Tunisie et ensuite le
ministre de l'Intérieur
Darmanin et la ministre de l'Intérieur
d'Allemagne avait l'intention également
de faire des actions conjointes donc
tout le monde se parle et ce coordonne
et l'intérêt n'est évidemment pas on a
tous intérêt à le faire de façon
coordonnée et pas tomber dans un piège
ou
des pays pourraient nous
instrumentaliser
monsieur le sénateur Marie vous m'avez
mentionné quatre points le premier étant
ce sujet de l'unanimité qui je pense est
effectivement
un sujet très important alors il y a des
décisions comme vous savez qui se
prennent à la majorité qualifiée et on
essaye et je crois que le Président de
la République est vraiment été à
l'avant-garde de ça de plaider pour
réformer la gouvernance sur les points
où ça peut être quand on parle par
exemple des amis de la majorité
qualifiée en matière d'affaires
étrangère pour l'instant on se concentre
sur des points qui sont des points
humanitaires qui sont des missions
civiles puisque bien sûr il y a des
prérogatives des Affaires étrangères qui
devront rester national mais donc c'est
ça va faire partie des points
qui devront être discutés et
probablement revu pour certains sujets
lorsqu'on parlera de réforme de l'Union
européenne ou transformation de la
gouvernance de l'Union européenne dans
la perspective de l'élargissement mais
aussi pour qu'on puisse fonctionner un
plus de façon plus fluide
en ce qui concerne la
pose réglementaire
et je vais très claire la France veut
aller au bout de tous les règlements qui
sont prévus en application du pacte vert
l'objectif est bien de réduire les
émissions de 55% d'ici à 2030 et
d'arriver à la neutralité climatique
d'ici à 2050 et c'est ce que le
président de la République elle est
je crois il faut le répéter parce que je
pense qu'on n'entend pas assez l'Europe
et la région du monde la plus en pointe
en matière de transition énergétique et
d'écologie en général maintenant ce que
le président ce que nous voulons faire
c'est évaluer l'impact des normes qui
ont été prises
accompagnés ceux qui en ont besoin et
par ailleurs que la Commission
effectivement
facilite des soutiens financiers qui
sont nécessaires pour la transition
voilà donc
c'est pas une on ne veut pas de
surenchère réglementaire on veut
l'application et les financements qui
vont avec je reviendrai sur le ce qui
m'amène d'ailleurs
à la transition sur le fond de
souveraineté c'est un début pour ces
pour ses financements qui vont nous
aider à faire la transition vous savez
aussi qu'il y a les fonds sociaux qui
sont de l'ordre de 80 milliards
et en ce qui concerne la réponse à l'IRA
ce n'est pas que le fond de souveraineté
la réponse à l'IRA c'est trois choses
c'est la simplification en matière
d'herbe de règlement
avec un abaissement des seuils de façon
elle est beaucoup plus vite parce que ce
que fait l'IRA c'est quand même des
choses simples donc il faut qu'on
réduise la bureaucratie de façon massive
et pour les pieds qu'on en avait parlé
passé d'autorisation qui demande deux
ans à des autorisations qui devraient
durer moins qui devrait être fait en six
mois donc il y a un élément
simplification un élément est d'État
national
l'élément fonde souveraineté de façon à
ce qui est aucun pays qui puisse faire
des arrêts des tas massives au détriment
d'autres c'est vraiment pas le moment de
se faire de la concurrence là dessus
et quand le président de la République
avait répondu à des questions à ce sujet
à la suite du Conseil européen de
février il avait bien présenté
l'ensemble des financements qui sont
possibles comme une réponse qui serait
équivalente à 400 milliards d'euros donc
on match en bon français les fonds qui
sont mis à disposition aux États-Unis et
j'en veux pour preuve prenez le cas de
des usines qui ont été inaugurées par le
ministre Bruno Le Maire qui notamment
dans les batteries ou dans l'hydrogène
qui sont des premières qui sont de très
gros investissements qui se chiffre en
plusieurs milliards on a vu aussi la
même chose en Allemagne avec un tel
sur le Mercosur je peux vous assurer
d'abord que le Conseil UEC ne sera pas
que sur ce sujet et ensuite que la
position de la France est très claire et
n'a pas changé on a vu l'occasion d'en
parler
il ne peut pas y avoir d'accord
commercial qui ne soit pas un accord
d'abord stratégique avec de la
réciprocité et qui respecte les accords
de Paris nos normes environnementales et
sociales y compris sur la déforestation
et par ailleurs pas de division des
accords commerciaux c'est une ligne
rouge de la France le Parlement français
doit avoir son mot à dire surtout après
la proposition de résolution qui a été
faite
sur le contrat de financement
plus réelle je crois que j'ai répondu
sur l'aspect fond de souveraineté sur la
ressources propres vous avez
complètement raison il doit y avoir plus
de travail à ce sujet on y évidemment
pas
il y a pas tout ce qu'il faut c'est
clair il y a le macf le marché carbone
mais ça suffira pas on l'a dit à la
Commission et donc on va attendre des
propositions dans les prochains mois et
on veut comprendre un petit peu mieux
c'est éventuel taxe sur les entreprises
sur le règlement ASAP et notamment
l'article 13 je peux vous assurer que
nous ne fournirons jamais à la
Commission des choses auxquelles le
Parlement français n'aurait pas accès et
les dispositions ont fait elles vous
faites allusion que ce soit le
dispositif de cartographie des
vulnérabilités dans les chaînes
d'approvisionnement que ce soit la
possibilité pour la commission de
prioriser des commandes notamment en
produits de pays tiers que ce soit les
dispositions allégeantes de contrôle
export toutes ces dispositions ont été
écartées et donc maintenant nous allons
pouvoir procéder au trilogue
ça c'est pour la question politique que
vous m'avez adressée sur les aspects
économie économiques et industriels et
l'harmonisation à nouveau et la France
est très claire sur les intérêts de sa
base industrielle de défense et
continueront à de se barre dessus nous
sommes toujours sur la même position qui
est que nous devons développer plus
l'industrie de défense européennes à
partir notamment de ces industries
existantes et que quand il y a
financement européen c'est pour aller à
des capacités de production européenne
et à des achats européens merci
merci monsieur le Président moi j'ai une
première question très générale mais
nous sommes à la veille des élections
européennes donc ma question c'est les
Français que pensent-ils de
l'élargissement de l'Union européenne
ensuite vous avez parlé de de la santé
ça c'est ça fait partie des dossiers que
je suis avec ma collègue Laurence
haribet donc nous avons j'ai posé une
question tout à l'heure à l'ambassadeur
concernant le paquet pharmaceutique et
si les débats seront seront poussés en
fait pour arriver à la finalité que nous
attendons et dans dans ce sujet de des
médicaments
nous avons j'ai participé aussi à la
commission d'enquête sur la pénurie de
médicaments en France et donc quand vous
parlez de relocalisation qui va décider
du type de production
médicamenteuse qui vont revenir sur
sur enfin dans l'Union européenne
avec quand même comme sujet des usines
souvent
ces vaisseaux plus plus
parce que finalement ça si un peu sur
sur les normes quand c'est fait très
loin très loin de nous mais ça fait
partie des questions qui sont qui sont
posées
nous avons rendu aussi un rapport sur
les données de santé vous en avez vous
en avez parlé on a fait des propositions
j'espère que vous voulez regarder et
avec Laurence arrivée nous sommes bien
sûr à votre disposition pour pour en
parler parce que à la fois c'est
important parce que au sein de l'Union
européenne tout le monde voyage que ce
soit professionnel allemand que ce soit
pour les études que ce soit aussi pour
la vie personnelle on a aussi nos
régions transpontières et donc on a
besoin en fait de ce partage de données
de santé pour
de enquête de problèmes pour pour une
personne un patient et puis deuxièmement
pour la recherche dont on a toujours
vraiment besoin
particulièrement pour les maladies rares
particulièrement pour pour le cancer les
cancers pédiatriques donc on a vraiment
besoin de se partage mais en même temps
il faut faire attention et surtout
vis-à-vis des pays tiers qui sont
là autour de nous pour récupérer ces
données de santé pour pas toujours pour
un but très humanitaire et juste juste
une question encore sur les travailleurs
de plateforme parce que ce dossier
n'avance pas
je ne sais pas si on arrivera au bout un
moment donné je sais que la France
n'est pas très favorable finalement à ce
qu'une majorité au sein de l'Union
européenne souhaiterait particulièrement
sur sur le salariat voilà et sur le
merco sourd bien entendu je vous ai je
suis d'accord avec vous vous paraissez
très ferme sur sur les mêmes normes mais
en revanche monsieur l'ambassadeur
d'Espagne n'était pas aussi ferme que
vous en disant qu'il fallait avancer pas
à pas et qu'il fallait peut-être laisser
un peu voilà un peu d'ouverture moi je
pense que on peut pas demander à aux
Français aux agriculteurs
d'avoir de respecter des normes les
français demandent à manger de plus en
plus sainement et puis accepter en fait
d'introduire des produits qui seraient
pas dans nos normes merci
bonjour madame la ministre j'ai trois
trois questions rapides
la première concernant l'Ukraine et le
sommet de l'OTAN
vous avez redis
tout à l'heure
reparler de garantie de sécurité aussi
autour de cette notion là que les
Européens allaient aller avancer leur
position
au sommet de binus c'est ce que vous
m'aviez répondu dans l'hémicycle dans le
débat préalable au Conseil européen
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus
sur ce que recouvre cette formule c'est
à dire derrière cette formule de
garantie de sécurité de qu'est-ce que
concrètement ça peut vouloir dire dans
ce que serait mis serait mis sur la
table à l'OTAN au sommet de l'OTAN et à
propos du sommet de l'OTAN est-ce que
les Européens j'entends bien la
discussion d'Union européenne vont à ce
sommet pour ce qui est des pays membres
avec des positions
égal ou
diverses
la deuxième chose elle concerne mais mon
DJ Marie est déjà intervenus vous avez
répondu
[Musique]
sur le cadre financier pluriannuel enfin
sur
ce qu'on a du mal à percevoir quand même
c'est sur tous les enjeux de
souveraineté de réindustrialisation les
plus diverses mais y compris Pascal
Bruni vient de parler de la santé ce
matin il y a les la remise la
publication du rapport de la commission
d'enquête du Sénat sur les pénuries de
médicaments qui fait un certain nombre
de de préconisations
surtout ces sujets là on voit bien qu'on
est quand même pour le moment on manque
de financement et on est on est quand
même dans un paradoxe qui est que on a
on a ouvert un peu les vannes
budgétaires pendant la période covid ont
l'impression que la période koskovie
dont va être plutôt dans une période
de restriction budgétaire or c'est
pourtant à ce moment là qu'il faut
s'attaquer au financement de toute la
reconquête de nos souverainetés donc on
sait tous qui faut mettre beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent sur la table dans
beaucoup de domaines
donc la question des
du financement de tous ces plans
je pense qu'on est loin d'être au bout
de ce sujet et on voit pas bien bon
comment on va résoudre cette contraction
et la dernière chose j'avais pas prévu
poser la question mais puisque vous
l'avez évoqué d'un mot ça
m'intéresserait que vous en disiez plus
sur ce qui est dit à propos de Chypre
c'est à dire est-ce qu'il y a une
tentative une discussion à nouveau de
l'Union européenne pour tenter
la relance d'une
d'une initiative politique sur sur
Chypre ça m'intéresserait de de
connaître ce qui s'est dit au Conseil
européen sur ça parce que vous l'avez
évoqué
ça m'intéresse
merci merci monsieur le Président merci
madame la ministre le sujet n'ayant pas
été évoqué donc je me permets de poser
la question c'est d'avoir un peu plus de
précision par rapport à l'avancement
justement des négociations sur le marché
d'électricité on sait très bien que les
positions sont divergentes le ministre
Bruno Le Maire a déclaré encore
récemment qu'il fallait des prix qui
soit proches des prix de production
notamment des mixtes énergétiques
nationaux on voit que l'Espagne elle
dirait pousse sur le renouvelable ils
ont aussi mis en place un mécanisme
qu'on appelle le mécanisme
ibérique d'une certaine façon donc que
l'Allemagne elle est également une
position divergente donc comment arriver
une certaine façon à faire converger sur
une position commune qui puisse aider à
permettre à la France à la fois de bien
évidemment de protéger les consommateurs
mais aussi d'avoir de la visibilité
notamment pour pour les entreprises
puisque la reine elle va disparaître en
néanmoins les entreprises qui vont
s'engager notamment dans des contrats à
long terme vont commencer à négocier fin
2023 voire 2024 des contrats qui vont
durer sur plusieurs années donc voilà il
y a à l'heure actuelle un certain flou
et une certaine urgence pour pour le
monde économique d'avoir un prix de
l'énergie enfin d'électricité qui soit
stable
merci monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup pour ces questions
donc Madame la vice-présidente Grigny
sur les élections européennes et
l'élargissement je vais faire trois
points d'abord il y a des étapes et un
calendrier pour prendre des décisions
d'ouverture des négociations qui ne sont
pas la fermeture des négociations et que
c'est cette décision elle est elle aura
nous ont un rapport formel en octobre de
la Commission européenne sur les progrès
en matière de condition qui ont été
mises pour ouvrir ces négociations et
une décision a priori en décembre l'idée
est bien évidemment de renforcer les
procédures pardon de parler de
procédures dans les deux sens à la fois
la procédure des procédures de réforme
des états candidats pour que ce soit
peut-être plus rapide mais surtout plus
solide et puis la procédure de
transformation d'Union Européenne pour
s'assurer de la solidité des
institutions on a vu dans la période
récente à quel point c'est important et
enfin aucune décision de ce type n'est
prise vous le savez sans consultation
simplement et éventuellement de la
population
sur le paquet
pharmaceutique les médicaments et les
données de santé d'abord permettez-moi
de vous dire que bien sûr nous allons
nous avons suivi la proposition de
résolution que vous avez adopté hier et
que je suis à disposition pour discuter
des propositions que vous avez avec vous
puisque comme vous le savez on forme la
position française à l'Union européenne
à partir de des positions des
parlementaires et des discussions en
interministérielle donc votre
contribution est bien évidemment
essentiel vous m'avez posé la question
de qui prend la décision de où se mettre
les entreprises je vais vous dire c'est
chaque État et comme vous savez en
France on est en train de relocaliser
aussi mes souvenirs sont bons au moins
deux usines de production de médicaments
maintenant le Conseil européen a invité
la Commission à proposer une initiative
en vue de l'adoption de mesure urgentes
pour assurer une production et une
disponibilité suffisante en Europe des
médicaments les plus critiques c'est le
critical médicinal et bien sûr nous
allons étudier et bien sûr je moi je
suis à votre disposition pour en parler
[Musique]
sur les travailleurs des plateformes
alors le dossier avance comme vous savez
les trilogues sont ouverts puisqu'il y a
eu un accord au conseil epsco du 12 juin
2023 pour améliorer à la fois les
conditions de travail et les droits
sociaux des personnes qui travaillent
via une plateforme l'objectif vous le
connaissez c'est celui de disposer d'un
cadre commun au niveau de l'Union pour
encadrer ces nouvelles formes de travail
et nous allons aussi voulu à la fois
mieux protéger les travailleurs des
plateformes mais aussi préserver la
liberté des indépendants qui sont
nombreux en France et bien sûr dans les
trilogues nous allons veiller à ce que
cet équilibre soit préservé notamment en
ce qui concerne et ce qui j'imagine vous
concerne et qui est la présomption de
salariat
sur le Mercosur c'est pas un mystère
effectivement que l'Espagne y attache
partie beaucoup d'importance c'est vrai
qu'il y a des enjeux stratégiques
notamment parce qu'il y a d'importantes
réserves de lithium dans ces pays comme
il y en a au Chili mais c'est important
pour nous aussi que nous ayons des
mesures miroirs ainsi peut-être un point
que je n'avais pas émotionné avant et
que évidemment quand on demande à nos
agriculteurs de respecter des normes on
les implique on fait à la transparence
sur les autres je crois que le modèle en
la matière c'est vraiment l'accord que
nous avons signé à la Nouvelle-Zélande
et pour nous c'est le nouveau
référentiel en matière d'accord
commerciaux
monsieur le vice-président Laurent donc
vous m'avez interrogé sur ce que voulait
dire c'est garantie de sécurité
il y a trois points qui sont importants
je crois et à retenir la première c'est
d'abord ce qui correspond à une
pérennisation de la facilité européenne
de paix qui comme vous savez permet de
fournir des équipements des munitions et
ce qu'on veut qui dure dans le temps
c'est à hauteur de 5 milliards à peu
près par an pour nous Union européenne
il y a évidemment un engagement des
Américains sur ce sujet aussi de même on
veut continuer la formation des soldats
vous savez que nous avions un objectif
de 30000 soldats Ukrainiens formés sur
le sol européen d'ici à la fin de
l'année et il faut évidemment que ça
continue dans le temps et puis un
renforcement des capacités de production
aussi on en a parlé tout à l'heure vous
avez sans doute vu que l'Estonie avait
fait une proposition en la matière que
nous avons regardé que le président a
regardé avec un oeil favorable qui
évidemment consiste en fait à cette
économie de guerre dont nous parlions
l'idée générale étant que tout ce que
nous avons fait on puisse se prolonger
suffisamment dans le temps pour que ce
soit très dissuasif pour des puissances
non amicales
en ce qui concerne les médicaments
et les et tout ce qui est
réindustrialisation souveraineté et
mesure de financement vous avez raison
alors nous on a beaucoup assisté à la
fois sur les aides d'État sur la
flexibilité dans l'utilisation des fonds
sur laquelle il faut que la Commission
aille plus loin et sur le fond de
souveraineté et je crois que votre
question s'est inscrit dans un temps
plus long avec celui de des
investissements dans la défense la
transition énergétique la transition
numérique et puis j'ai rajouté la
reconstruction du crâne tout ça va
demander finalement des financements
importants c'est pour ça qu'ils font de
contrat et beaucoup plus sur les
ressources propres et qu'on est temps de
la possibilité de ressources propres et
puis peut-être se posera un moment la
question effectivement d'un nouvel
emprunt commun pour faire face à toutes
ces à toutes ces transitions
sur la question de Chypre effectivement
chez Philippe prend un demande que
l'Union européenne s'implique plus et on
a fait état au Conseil européen
effectivement nous sommes dans une
nouvelle période après les élections qui
ont eu lieu à la fois hachypres et puis
en Turquie je vous ai Borel pendant le
conseil il y a effectivement
communiquer Ruddy sa disponibilité à
faciliter les échanges avec prudence
mais c'est aussi notre intérêt que la
que cette ce sujet soit traitée soit
traitée en européen
monsieur le sénateur Houlgate sur la
réforme de l'électricité
il y a plusieurs points et sur lesquels
je crois que nous sommes complètement
d'accord d'abord la neutralité
technologique et extrêmement importante
nous le redisons sur chaque texte qui
touche à l'énergie que ce soit
d'ailleurs la réforme du marché
d'électricité que ce soit le texte raide
que vous avez sûrement suivi et que ce
soit d'ailleurs le net zéro industriel
qui là aussi un doigt à comprendre en
son sein la neutralité technologique
et donc ça veut dire qu'on va respecter
l'énergie mixe des autres et qu'on
s'attend à ce qu'il respecte le nôtre et
comme vous l'avez dit l'enjeu est à la
fois un enjeu de prix de visibilité ce
qu'il croyait vraiment un pilier de la
compétitivité européenne et
d'investissement le mécanisme ibérique
ça va s'arrêter à la fin de l'année tout
comme la reine d'ailleurs devrait
s'arrêter en 2025 dans le texte vous
m'arrêtez quand je vous ennuie avec trop
de détails techniques mais les
discussions sont maintenant sur les
contrats pour différences et là je crois
qu'il y a des marges de négociation qui
nous permettront à nous d'avoir un prix
stable et qui reflète tous les
investissements que nous avons fait dans
le passé et pour lequel nous pouvaient
pas payer deux fois et en même temps qui
prend en compte aussi la nécessité
d'investir plus et qui permettent aussi
aux autres d'investir
en conséquence voilà
merci beaucoup madame la ministre madame
la ministre un petit point juste à la
fin je vous ai montré tout à l'heure un
message d'un communiqué de presse
AFP disant que l'agent européenne des
droits fondamentaux avec la rivière que
la France était un état policier
assimilé à un état raciste et une police
raciste
je voudrais savoir si le gouvernement va
réagir fortement à ses propos parce que
moi j'en ai assez de voir mon pays
salie en permanence et si les agences
demain prennent le dessus comme c'est le
cas en France de ce que peut être un
parlement de ce que peut être un
gouvernement de ce que peut être une
commission on n'a pas fini d'en discuter
donc moi je veux savoir c'est réellement
si le gouvernement va réagir à cela
parce que l'Agence européenne des droits
fondamentaux c'est c'est la même qui
intervient sur sur Frontex et qui qui
empêche finalement un travail
un travail évolutif le contexte moi je
voilà je suis exaspéré de voir ça et
j'espère que vous comprenez mon
exaspération
de m'avoir montré ça alors je vais être
très clair il y a ça il y a eu Didier
nders qui s'est exprimé aussi je l'ai
dit à la radio ce matin il n'est pas de
la compétence de Digne render c'est de
la Commission européenne de s'intéresser
à la façon dont la France gère les
forces de l'ordre et donc il y a un
rapport état droit qui est sorti hier
dans la Commission et les forces de
l'ordre ne sont pas discutées dans ce
rapport il n'y a pas de racisme
systémique dans la police le ministre
Darmanin a dit plusieurs ministres se
sont exprimés à ce propos et je crois
qu'il ne faut pas confondre les actions
d'une personne ou un acte sur lequel les
lois de la République vont s'appliquer
il y aura de la justice personne
négligea pas la justice en France et au
loin ni les citoyens ni un agent de
police mais je l'ai dit très clairement
sur RFI ce matin Didier Reynders n'est
pas compétent sur ce sujet et en
attendant qu'il ne fasse pas ce genre de
déclaration et quand à l'Agence
européenne de droit fondamentaux va bien
évidemment regarder plus en détail ce
qu'ils ont dit et réagir s'il le faut
merci Madame la Ministre quand on parle
d'union d'union ça nécessite aussi de la
part des de ceux qui la constitue des
institutions qui la constitue à respect
des États membres peut-être que l'union
sera plus facile dans ce sens là
merci beaucoup madame la ministre et ben
finalement regardez en une heure on a
fait le travail c'est parfait merci à
vous et à une prochaine fois pour
maintenant je pense que ce sera la
rentrée
merci à vous c'est toujours un plaisir
de discuter avec vous et merci pour
toutes vos questions qui nous permettent
de rentrer un peu plus dans les détails
merci